ntw correspondent fannie farchar is in
kiev for us funny plans for a council
offensive in the south fighting of
course continues in the east where are
things on day 156 of the war
you kind of get the impression that this
is a level of stagnation for both sides
because there weren't any major gains
during recent weeks neither for russia
nor for ukraine while at the same time
as we have also heard in that report
there's a lot of shelling going on
specifically in bhagmot which is a very
strategic town for russians to take in
to then advance in the donbass region
towards slovans which is the
administrative center in donetsk so a
lot of fighting is going on without any
help there in the eastern region but the
situation is also quite dynamic in the
harrison region as ukraine is trying to
step off step up its counter offensive
there and liberate harrison city that is
under russian control since the very
beginning almost of the war that is in
its six months now there's focus on this
key bridge the antonivsky bridge which
also changed hands a few times during
the course of this war and ukraine wants
to control this bridge because you if
you look at the map you see that it
really establishes a land corridor for
russians from crimea all the way into
central ukraine and it is actually very
very important for them to supply their
their forces their troops in the city
but also in on the western bank of the
river of the nepal river with very
important to us with very important gear
etc so you will see a much more action
to say so in the hasson region of course
at the same time it's going to be the
civilians have to be the brand for this
as ukraine is stepping up counter
offensive without any major gains yet
just preparing the ground for it and
russia of course will want to defend the
region that they have taken in a few
months ago
now finally there's also of course the
ongoing grain issue with speculation
things could start moving today where do
things stand there
if you listen to the un chief mr
griffiths there he said that things look
good in the sense that this could start
today at the same time a quote there are
crucial details that have not been
worked out yet now one of those crucial
details of course is the question of
safety you have to know all these ports
there along the black sea uh
specifically the odessa port are mined
this is what ukraine set up in order to
defend the ports from russian
advancement but at the same time now you
need a safe corridor for the ships to
leave the port get to turkey back and
back and forth to export the grain so
these are things in terms of safety that
really need to be worked out in fact
just yesterday we heard about two
casualties that were two people swimming
along the on along the coastline and
unfortunately they've been blown up by a
sea mine so it is a very realistic and a
very probable threat there that needs to
be worked out the logistics here the
safety in order for this to really start
and the ship the first ships setting
sail there from odessa
all right funny thank you very much for
that update dw's funny fact in kiev